[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und marietta slomka
guten abend man befinde sich an einem
ganz besonderen tag der pandemie
erklärte heute bundeskanzler stolz als
er den lockerungs plan präsentierte auf
den sich bund und länder geeinigt haben
wobei ein ich hier ja immer relativ ist
der umgang mit dem virus bleibt
weiterhin föderal unterschiedlich aber
es gibt einen gemeinsamen plan bis 20
märz stufenweise sollen corona maßnahmen
zurückgenommen werden danach ist nur
noch ein sogenannter basisschutz
vorgesehen was heißt das konkret habe
ich den vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gefragt hendrik wüst vor dem interview
der bericht von andrea maurer
von einem guten tag von optimismus
sprechen die politisch handelnden heute
oft nicht mehr lange und alle tief
greifenden schutzmaßnahmen sollen
wegfallen genau genommen am 20 märz vom
freedom day wie es teile der fdp tun
will der kanzler trotzdem nicht sprechen
ich halte von solchen begriff nicht sie
werden dem fenster lager nicht
angemessen schrittweise nimmt
deutschland nun kurs richtung öffnung
als erstes entfallen kontakt
beschränkungen für geimpfte und genesen
und die kontrollen im einzelhandel
zugang haben alle allerdings weiter nur
mit maske abführten märz dürfen wieder
mehr zuschauer zu großveranstaltungen in
gastronomie und hotels geht dann 3g ab
zwanzigster märz sollen dann alle
tiefgreifenden schutz maßnahmen
entfallen auch die home office pflicht
auf einen basisschutz wie masken pflicht
für die zeit danach drängen die
länderchefs handlungsfähig bleiben sie
bitten den bundestag um den gesetzlichen
rahmen
wenn der bundestag nicht aktiv handelt
laufen ab dem 20 märz alle
schutzmaßnahmen aus dem fallen schlicht
alle maßnahmen die wir bisher noch
kennen weg pandemie richtet sich aber
nicht nach dem kalender
die befürchtung der länder die fdp
könnte eine regelung im bundestag
blockieren
kanzler verspricht sich persönlich für
einen gesetzlichen rahmen einzusetzen
gehört ausdrücklich gesagt er will sich
dafür einsetzen hat aber auch gesagt er
könne nicht für seine regierung sprechen
und das war jetzt nicht drumrumreden das
weiß doch jeder muss problem liegt jeder
weiß wo das problem liegt und diese
koalition muss sich entscheiden ob sie
zu irgend einer gemeinsamen position
kommt die fdp das mögliche problem lässt
heute wissen sie halte eine verlängerung
zumindest der masken pflicht für denkbar
aber wichtig ist auch eines
freiheitseinschränkung müssen immer
begründet werden der selbstverständliche
verfassungsrechtliche normalzustand ist
dass es keine freiheitseinschränkung in
deutschland gibt und es ist richtig zu
diesem verfassungs normalzustand ab dem
20 mehr zurückzukehren an der
notwendigkeit einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht ändern die lockerungen
nichts daran lässt der kanzler keinen
zweifel es gehe darum vorbereitet zu
sein für herbst und winter dazu ist das
mit der impfpflicht unverändert wichtig
das will ich noch mal festhalten die
einigkeit die 16 länder und der
bundeskanzler in dieser frage haben
besteht fort wir finden zu 17 das ist
richtig ist ansonsten haben sechs länder
den beschlüssen protokollerklärungen
angehängt in denen sie sich abweichungen
vorbehalten oder einwände vorbringen es
ist wohl so wie berlins regierende
bürgermeisterin heute sagt zu lockern
ist mindestens so schwierig wie
maßnahmen zu erlassen
und darüber wollen wir reden mit dem
aktuellen vorsitzenden der mpk mit
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst guten abend herr wüst
schimpfte slomka was sicherlich viele
bundesbürger und bürgerinnen am meisten
interessiert ist diese zeit nach dem 19
bis dann sollen wie es heißt tiefer
greifende maßnahmen entfallen das klingt
wuchtig aber ist zugleich sehr vage was
heißt das dass wir dann genau so
eigentlich alle beschränkungen fallen
lassen wie in der schweiz klammer auf
immer vorausgesetzt die lage gibt es
ihrer ansicht nach her klammer zu
wir sind jetzt in der situation in der
wir grundrechtseingriffe zurücknehmen
können aber wir müssen das verbinden mit
achtsamkeit und dazu gehört ein
basisschutz auch über den 19 märz hinaus
abstand halten maske tragen
test
vorzeigen von genesenen zertifikaten
alles bewährte mittel die wir kennen das
muss nicht heißen dass wir die alle
brauchen nach dem 19 aber wir brauchen
eine rechtsgrundlage dafür und stand
jetzt fällt nach dem 19 märz alles an
schutzmaßnahmen in deutschland weg also
auch zugangsbeschränkungen für
ungeimpfte zum beispiel oder oder masken
pflichten generellen supermarkt also wie
hat man sich das konkret vorzustellen
abstand halten ein disco wird es ja auch
nicht geben
nein aber wir wollen jedenfalls da wo
das pandemische geschehen ist dann noch
erfordert eben auf diese maßnahmen
zurückgreifen das sind eben basis
schutzmaßnahmen denn wir gehen die
schritte der öffnung ja in der annahme
dass die gute entwicklung dieser tage
weitergeht wir scheinen die omikron
welle nachhaltig überstanden zu haben
was den höhepunkt angeht und es geht
jetzt weiter runter aber wir brauchen
eben zur absicherung dieser öffnungen
die möglichkeiten eines basisschutz ist
weder der rechtsgrundlage genau das ist
ja so fallen wobei ist nicht genau
definiert ist wann der eintritt oder auf
welcher hospitalisierung rate oder
abwickeln toten täglich da gibt es ja
keine zahl wo man sagt jetzt wird es uns
dann doch zu heikel inzidenz braucht man
ja nicht mehr angucken es wird ja gar
nicht mehr so viel getestet dann wir
gucken immer schon auf mehrere
indikatoren die vom verfassungsgericht
klar beschriebenen voraussetzungen für
schwerwiegende grundrechtseingriffe es
sind die aufrechterhaltung der
kritischen infrastruktur insbesondere
des gesundheitswesens was man ja damit
signalisiert ist weil es ja eben auch
für ungeimpfte nicht mehr solche
probleme gibt den laden zu gehen oder
gastronomie zu gehen dass man diese
ursprünglich ja ich sag mal
erzieherische maßnahme ist ungeimpften
schwer zu machen das war ja auch eine
intention hinter diesen beschränkungen
dass man das jetzt eigentlich
aufgibt
das impfen bleibt weiter wichtig aber
diese ganzen regeln die wir kennen aus
den letzten monaten zwei g2 g + etc
finden eben ihr ende dann und müssen ist
auch finden wenn die pandemische lage
diese regeln eben nicht mehr erzwingen
und in dieser guten situation
wenn man einmal festhalten in dieser
guten situation sind wir jetzt
wir haben den höhepunkt der mikrowelle
erreicht ab jetzt geht's hoffentlich in
die richtige richtung na ja aber das war
jetzt keine antwort eigentlich auf die
frage was signalisiert man den
ungeimpften damit also einerseits sagt
die politik leute bitte lasst euch
impfen und gleichzeitig sagt man aber
wenn er es nicht tut ist eigentlich auch
kein problem das ist vor allen dingen
ein problem für die ungeimpften selber
denn kurve in all seinen varianten
bleibt gefährlich aber wir sehen eben
jetzt durch omikron dass keine gefahr
mehr davon ausgeht das gesundheitssystem
überlastet sein sein könnte dass die
kritische infrastruktur
stabil werden könnte und insofern ist es
dann eine frage des individual schutzes
aber nicht des schutzes von
gemeinschaftsrechts gütern die
schwerwiegende verfassungsrechtliche
eingriffe weiterhin rechtfertigen würden
und die wohl nach haben sind dann
eigentlich auch darauf angewiesen für
sich selbst sozusagen zu sorgen bleiben
sie dann in nordrhein-westfalen dabei
das ist eine teil impfpflicht gibt im
gesundheitsbereich einige cdu länder
sehen das ja inzwischen anders
wir sind uns alle einig dass für die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
brauchen gerade um die wohlhabenden zu
schützen und um deren schutz geht es uns
eben auch bei den basisschutz maßnahmen
denn auch das muss möglich sein in einer
einrichtung für wohlhabende personen
leben wo sie sind krankenhaus
behinderteneinrichtung oder ähnliches
noch eine maske pflicht zu verhängen
nach lage der dinge wäre auch dafür die
rechtsgrundlage nach dem 19 märz weg das
ist unser anliegen der länder dass wir
eine solche rechtsgrundlage bereite ich
meinen kameraden zu schützen meint aber
jetzt die teil im pflicht da hat ja
sogar als erstes gesagt das kriegen wir
nicht hin das lässt sich nicht umsetzen
und ihre parteivorsitzende friedrich
merz hat gesagt wir sollten jetzt mal
bundesweit erstmal aussetzen das ganze
hat er das eigentlich mit ihnen
abgestimmt wir sind uns alle einig dass
wir diese sektor bezogene einrichtungs
bezogen eine impfpflicht brauchen wir
sind uns aber genauso einig dass an sehr
vielen dingen noch gearbeitet werden
muss bis sie wirksam umgesetzt werden
kann zum beispiel arbeitsrechtliche
fragen sind zu klären
darüber gibt es im übrigen kein zweifel
auch über parteigrenzen hinweg dass da
noch viele fragen offen sind warum fällt
das eigentlich jetzt plötzlich auf im
dezember wollten die cdu länder
unbedingt dass diese teil impfpflicht
schon im offenen jahr also bis ende 2021
jetzt drei monate später sagt man obst
kriegen wir gar nicht hin ja wir haben
wie so oft in der pandemie in einem
guten einvernehmen zwischen bund und
ländern die grundsatzentscheidung
getroffen haben dann im bundesrat
zugestimmt weil die zusage da war es wir
zügig an diesen themen gearbeitet dann
gegen die zeit ins land es wurde nicht
zügig genug daran gearbeitet und
deswegen gab es eben auch die situation
der letzten woche die sind uns aber
einig dass wir sie brauchen dass wir sie
wollen und wir werden sie auch umsetzen
so weit es eben bei all den offenen
fragen geht aber wir brauchen sie um die
schwächsten der gesellschaft auch in
zukunft zu schützen danke für das
gespräch
sehr gerne frau slomka
nach dem heute-journal update gibt es
dazu dann noch ein interview mit der
politischen konkurrenz mit thomas
kutschaty dem spd oppositionsführer in
nordrhein westfalen
kommen wir zum zweiten
großthema dieser zeit dem konflikt mit
russland
gestern herrschte ja erstmal allgemeine
erleichterung nachdem wladimir putin
signalisierte dass man an diplomatie
weiter interessiert sei und sich sogar
schon teile der russischen truppen von
der grenze zur ukraine zurückziehen
würden heute macht sich da allerdings
eine gewisse ernüchterung breit an dem
truppenrückzug gibt es bei der nato
nämlich erhebliche zweifel
florian hand berichtet man kann sich an
alles gewöhnen an die ständigen
flugübungen etwa oder daran dass das
eigene land am rande eines krieges steht
mir hort ukraine fünf mal pro tag fliegt
alex ii eine halbe stunde training für
den ernstfall für die frage dieser tage
droht ein russische einmarsch
ich glaube ja nicht dass sie so einen
einmarsch erleben wie beim letzten mal
2014 mit der krim jetzt gibt es doch
erst mal einen informationskrieg
dieser begriff passt während der
kampfflieger der ukrainischen luftwaffe
mal wieder zur übung startet
veröffentlicht das russische
verteidigungsministerium heute solche
bilder die einen abzug russischer
truppen und panzer zeigen sollen ob aus
der krim oder einem nicht näher
benannten gebiet in der nähe der
ukrainischen grenze die bilder sind wie
maßgeschneidert für die
weltöffentlichkeit und sie wecken
misstrauen ist das alles nur show wir
werden nicht naiv sein sondern wir
werden genau beobachten welche maßnahmen
russland jetzt ergreift brüssel hier
treffen sich heute turnusgemäß die
verteidigungsminister der nato und hier
klingen alle die von diesem punkt aus
vor die kameras treten ähnlich englisch
skeptisch
wir freuen uns darauf beweise zu sehen
für einen russischen truppen abzug aber
wir müssen uns weiter auf alle
möglichkeiten vorbereitet
sie haben immer truppen hin und her
bewegt dass wir jetzt also bewegungen
von truppen oder panzern sehen das
bedeutet noch lange keinen echten
rückzug
man gewöhnt sich an vieles in dieser
krise auch daran dass täglich eine
anderer nato staat mehr soldaten nach
osteuropa schickt heute denkt die ganze
allianz darüber nach 2017 startete die
nato ihre verstärkte vorne präsenz mit
kampfgruppen zur verteidigung in estland
lettland litauen und in polen jetzt
denkt das bündnis an einer ausweitung
mit truppen etwa in rumänien
möglicherweise auch in bulgarien ungarn
der slowakei
weil man sich in europa wahrscheinlich
erklärt der nato generalsekretär werden
gewöhnen müssen an eine permanente
bedrohung durch russland
ich sage es ungern aber das ist die neue
normalität in europa es ist die deutsche
verteidigungsministerin die öffentlich
ein wenig auf die bremse tritt über neue
kampfgruppen in osteuropa werde man erst
im sommer entscheiden sollten wir nicht
in dieser aktuellen situation und vor
dem hintergrund der aktuellen situation
machen sondern nach einer intensiven
prüfung und unter beobachtung der
situation dann noch ist weiter offen was
russland vor hat mit der ukraine wo
kampfflieger alexy täglich seine runden
dreht und wo sie in kiew eine flagge
zeigen gegen den krieg weil die sich an
diese gefahr eben nicht gewöhnen wollen
die nato markt wieder enger
zusammengerückt seien angesichts des
konflikts mit russland doch unter den
europäern gibt es nach wie vor große
differenzen darüber welche gemeinsamen
demokratischen werte man vertritt und
mit dem thema geht es jetzt bei hanna
zimmermann weiter und zwar mit dem
rechtsstaat mechanismus und einem
wegweisenden urteil dazu verstößt ein
eu-land gegen die prinzipien der
rechtsstaatlichkeit dann darf die
kommission diesem land nämlich künftig
gelder streichen das hat der europäische
gerichtshof heute entschieden und damit
die klage von polen und ungarn
abgewiesen beide länder fürchten
kürzungen der polnische justizminister
kritisierte das urteil scharf ungarn
ebenso
wegen der korona pandemie arbeiten viele
menschen noch immer von zu hause aus und
auch in diesem jahr können sie das bei
der steuererklärung geltend machen mit
fünf euro pro tag für unternehmen soll
es teils verbesserte
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten geben das hat
heute das bundeskabinett beschlossen
viele länder kritisieren dass
pharmaunternehmen die bayern tag ihre
patente nicht freigeben jetzt wird das
mainzer unternehmen seinen corona
impfstoff ab kommendem jahr auch in
afrika selbst herstellen und hat dafür
mobile produktionsstätten entwickelt die
container sollen unter anderem an ruanda
und dem senegal geliefert werden darin
soll nicht nur der mma impfstoff gegen
korona produziert werden sondern später
auch solche gegen malaria und
tuberkulose nur rund elf prozent der
afrikanerinnen und afrikaner sollen
bisher vollständig gegen das virus
geimpft sein
der elfte märz soll in deutschland ein
nationaler gedenktag werden und zwar für
die opfer terroristischer gewalt diese
sollten nie vergessen werden sagte
bundesinnenministerium feser und nannte
die anschläge in halle und in hanau
einen europäischen gedenkt tag für
terroropfer gibt es bereits am 11 märz
dieser wurde 2005 nach den
bombenanschlägen auf mehrere züge in
madrid ins leben gerufen
der angeklagte der heute vorm
landgericht frankfurt stand erfüllt in
vieler hinsicht was man sich unter einem
gewaltbereiten extremisten mit hoher
krimineller energie vorstellt ihm wird
nicht nur vorgeworfen dass er
reihenweise menschen mit
volksverhetzenden drohschreiben in angst
und schrecken versetzt hat in der
anklage stehen außerdem noch
bombendrohungen tätlicher angriff auf
vollstreckungsbeamte
verstoß gegen das waffengesetz und
besitz von material mit sexualisierter
gewalt gegen kinder ein einzeltäter der
zum glück endlich dingfest gemacht wurde
doch so einfach ist es nicht nicht alle
betroffenen glauben dass er tatsächlich
ganz alleine handelte und selbst wenn er
tatsächlich ein einzeltäter war er ist
ja kein einzelfall zu sein santina
berichtet vom prozessauftakt
miese türken als vergeltung schlachten
wir deine tochter das fax unterschrieben
mit nsu 2.0 dabei jedes war die erste
wie solche drohschreiben bekommen hat
die anwältin erstattete anzeige und bei
den ermittlungen kam heraus dass ihre
zum teil gesperrten daten kurz vor der
drohung ohne anlass in dieser
polizeistation in frankfurt abgerufen
worden waren das abruft protokoll hat
sie dabei wildes vor kurzem gesehen und
fühlt sich bestätigt dass die
frankfurter polizei in die drohungen
gegen sie verwickelt ist
denn mein name wurde in polizeilichen
computer 17 mal in drei verschiedenen
polizeilichen datenbanken eingegeben und
90 minuten später wurden diese
informationen dafür verwendet dass meine
tochter bedroht wurde und ich
rassistisch beleidigt wurde in einem fax
vor gericht steht seit heute in
frankfurt aber nur alexander m der
angeklagte soll der verfasser von 116
rechtsextremen rassistischen trow
schreiben sein gleich zu beginn zeigte
der berliner deutlich was er von dem
prozess gegen ihn hält die
staatsanwaltschaft sieht bislang keine
verbindung zur polizei
innenminister peter beuth zeigt sich
deswegen erleichtert dass ich genau
dieser verdacht eben nicht bestätigt hat
sondern das ist ganz offensichtlich
dieser täter aus berlin war der sich
dann bei seiner tat ganz offensichtlich
die daten erschlichen hat die welle der
rechtsextremen drohschreiben begann im
august 2008 10 zu den bedrohten gehörten
neben der anwältin seema wildes auch die
kabarettistin idel beider oder die
linken-politikerin janine wissler
c dabei der yildiz glaubt nicht daran
dass alexander m sich als polizist aus
geben konnte warum sollte ein beamter
andere kollegin zum beispiel nach dem
namen ihrer zweijährigen tochter fragen
der war öffentlich nicht bekannt wurde
mit ropax aber genannt
und dann kommt noch hinzu dass die
beamtin von deren kennung die abfrage
erfolgt in einer rechtsextremen gruppe
aktiv war so viele zufälle gibt es nicht
seit aufdeckung dieser rechten jet
gruppe wurden 127 verfahren wegen
rechtsextremismus verdachts gegen
hessische polizisten eingeleitet für die
anklage gilt alexander als einzeltäter
für morgen hat er angekündigt umfassend
auszusagen und
jetzt nochmal hanna mit dem blick auf
die deutsche wirtschaft die löhne in
deutschland sind im vergangenen jahr
zwar gestiegen mehr leisten konnten sich
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
deshalb aber trotzdem nicht im gegenteil
die inflation war höher als das plus auf
der gehaltsabrechnung und frank bethmann
an der frankfurter börse das problem
könnte dieses jahr sogar noch größer
werden ja denn in diesem jahr drohen
sogar weitere einbußen beim reallohn
glaubt man den prognosen zur inflation
betrug sie im vergangenen jahr 3,1
prozent so erwartet die bundesregierung
in diesem jahr eine durchschnittliche
teuerung von 3,3 prozent die bundesbank
sogar eine von über vier prozent damit
die kaufkraft unterm strich nicht sinkt
müssten die löhne also in ähnlicher höhe
steigen die gewerkschaften verhandeln in
diesem jahr noch für rund 10 millionen
beschäftigte die neuen tariflöhne
sollten sie deutlich höhere löhne
durchsetzen besteht die gefahr einer
lohn preis spirale will sagen die
steigenden löhne könnten indirekt die
verbraucherpreise weiter nach oben
treiben dann nämlich wenn die
unternehmen die preise für ihre produkte
erhöhen um die gestiegenen gehälter
bezahlen zu können
nun hat sich heute außerdem
ezb-direktoriumsmitglied isabel schnabel
zur starken inflation geäußert steht nun
doch bald einen kurswechsel an na ja
interessant zu beobachten ist wie sich
das working bei der europäischen
zentralbank gerade ändert lange hatte
man ja leitzinserhöhungen noch in diesem
jahr ausgeschlossen begründung die hohe
inflation sei nur vorübergehend jetzt
räumte schnabel in einem interview einen
die teuerung sei weitaus hartnäckiger
als angenommen eine leitzinserhöhung nun
sogar im herbst denkbar auch weil der
druck wächst schließlich klagen einige
länder der eurozone wie beispielsweise
im baltikum inzwischen über zweistellige
inflationsraten vielen dank nach
frankfurt
es wird stürmisch und teilweise auch
gefährlich der deutsche wetterdienst hat
eine amtliche unwetterwarnung
herausgegeben vor orkanartigen böen bis
hin zu extremen orkanböen vor allem in
der nördlichen hälfte deutschlands an
der nordseeküste gibt es eine
sturmflutwarnung die fährverbindungen zu
den ostfriesischen inseln sind
vorsorglich ausgesetzt worden und in
ganz nrw fällt morgen der unterricht aus
mehrere andere bundesländer stellen den
schulbesuch frei märz um spuren gleich
in unserem ausführlichen wetterbericht
nach der olympia berichterstattung
fehlen noch die lottozahlen an diesem
mittwoch und die lauten 7 16 29 30 33 43
die superzahl 4 alle angaben wie immer
ohne gewähr
die berlinale ist natürlich eine andere
als sinnvoll kroner zeiten aber immerhin
findet sie überhaupt real statt uns
nicht nur online und heute abend gibt es
auch eine richtige bären verleihung mit
anwesender schauspiel und regie zunft
und jubelndem publikum alles zwar
reduziert und eine bären gala an einem
mittwoch gab es auch noch nie aber wozu
auch auf den bislang üblichen
samstagabend legen wenn es danach keine
abschlussparty gibt und so erinnert die
berlinale doch auch an das was fehlt und
ist in der hinsicht umweht von einer
gewissen traurigkeit
das passt aber vielleicht ganz gut zum
diesjährigen gewinner film stephan
merseburger berichtet es war ein wagnis
sie stattfinden zu lassen ohne partys
und empfänge zwar aber es hat sich
gelohnt die berlinale wurde
offensichtlich nicht zum super special
event sieben filme von frauen im
wettbewerb und lauter starke frauen
geschichten auf der leinwand die preise
für bestes drehbuch und die beste
hauptrolle gehen nach deutschland die
kölner comedian meltem kaptan gewinnt in
ihrer ersten titelrolle überhaupt gleich
einen silbernen bären
ich danke dir so sehr dass du mich auf
diese reise mitgenommen hast du bist der
beste reiseleiter die man sich
vorstellen kann
ich danke dir so sehr
in andreas dresens rabbi comas gegen
george bush gibt sie eine mutter die wie
eine löwin kämpft um ihren sohn morath
aus dem gefangenenlager guantanamo
herauszuholen
[Musik]
die spanierin carla simon 36 jahre jung
holt den goldenen bären für den besten
film eine familie betreibt eine kleine
pfirsich plantage im katalonischen
alcaraz die arbeit ist hart das geld
reicht kaum zum überleben
die pacht läuft aus die bäume sollen
durch solarpaneele ersetzt werden bei
kinect könnte in die zukunftsbranche
wechseln will aber nicht seine frau
dagegen erkennt dass er kaum eine andere
wahl hat
ich danke meiner familie die selbst
pfirsiche in alcaraz züchtet ohne die
nähe zu dieser welt hätte ich diese
geschichte nicht erzählen können
der große preis der jury ging an den
südkoreaner hong sangsoo es ist schon
sein dritter silberner bier der film der
schriftstellerin handelt von einer roman
autorin die eine reihe von zufälligen
begegnungen hat starke bilder in
ästhetischen schwarz-weiß
die mexikanerin natalia lopez gallardo
erhält den preis der jury gewandte aus
edelsteinen spielt im mexikanischen
staates morelos die drogenmafia lässt
menschen verschwinden drei frauen lehnen
sich dagegen auf ein bisweilen sperrige
aber atmosphärisch dichter film
dieser jahrgang hatte definitiv
frauenpower
das gefühl ich kann es gar nicht
beschreiben
ich habe ich auch wirklich ein paar tage
bis jetzt realisiere was sie eigentlich
passiert ist und ich bin irgendwie
völlig gaga und
weise melden captain auf wolke sieben
der berlinale sei dank
das wasser heute journal später im
auslandsjournal erwartet sie unter
anderem ein bericht über die korona
lockerungen in italien und gegen 0.45
gibt es dann unser heute-journal update
mit gundula gause ihm doch einen ruhigen
abend und passen sie den sturm gebieten
gut auf sich auf wir verabschieden uns
[Musik]
guten abend es sind gleich zwei
orkantiefs die uns in den nächsten tagen
beschäftigen werden zunächst mal die
ligna das heißt international du drei
und dann auch das orkantief zainab
international junis dieses erster linie
das wird bis freitag weiter nach
finnland ziehen und das ganz schnell
laufende orkantief das wird am freitag
schon dänemark erreichen jetzt aktuell
kommen die ersten kräftigen schauer und
gewitter hier im norden an und die
ziehen im laufe der nacht weiter
ostwärts wir haben jetzt schon schwere
sturmböen in deutschland auch
orkanartige sturmböen und orkanböen aber
es pfeift eigentlich in ganz deutschland
und dieses sturmfeld beschäftigt uns
morgen den ganzen tag über das sehen sie
hier an die orangen farbe erst am
freitag wird es dann vorübergehend ein
bisschen ruhiger aber schon
freitagnachmittag kommt der nächste
orkan heran und dieses orkantief das
orkan windfeld breitet sich dann aus bis
samstagfrüh heute nacht also gibt es
kräftige schauer und gewitter bei milden
temperaturen von 11 bis 5 grad und
morgen gibt es weitere kräftige schauer
allenfalls im südwesten haben sie etwas
sonnenschein die temperaturen liegen bei
8 bis 15 grad die böden sind aufgeweicht
und deswegen werden bäume umstürzen also
bringen sie sich in sicherheit bringen
sie alles in sicherheit was weg fliegen
könnte meiden sie wälder und verschieben
sie exkursionen das gilt für morgen es
gilt aber auch für freitagnachmittag und
für die nacht auf samstag am samstag
wird das orkantief dann ostwärts abzieht
guten abend